so what was what was the question tell
me again uh what was the first computer
game I played I'm setting up Sean's new
sound check 2023 we need a new sound
check question Steve suggested what's
the first computer game you ever played
what was the first game you played
computer game well the first computer
game I ever remember playing was
actually written by my dad um he wrote a
matching pairs type game that um on a
commodor pet I think it was with the
first computer I used I was about four
at the time and that's pretty much the
first one I remember playing of sort of
more traditional computer games with
sort of tradition computer game authors
and things um o uh I remember a version
of painter on the BBC micro and things
like The Hobbit on ZX spectrum and so on
so yeah that that dates me a bit first
computer game or first computer game you
were aware of um wrote myself mace uh
walking through the through mace program
on on a v 2,200 in
1976 Okay so still got
it
no was it challenging or did you was it
just fun I wouldn't myself and for my
friends but the writing of it was it fun
was it did you enjoy sure was was was
great fun I mean so the first video
games I I played the the writing was
more fun than than than playing them
yeah yeah okay actually the game I knew
about which I never played uh was a game
where you should cross a road and there
were cars coming yeah and then I wrote
my own version where you had to hit as
many cars as
possible I'm just going to check first
at the uh um the the audio is working so
can you can you remember your first uh
computer game that you ever played or my
first computer game I ever played was a
game on the old Amika something called
gold corn I was like three or four years
old oh yeah and did you did you complete
it did you just of course not it's so
difficult called even though when I
tried when I was a older yeah yeah that
was is the one of the first very members
I remember playing a video game I don't
know why I asked if you completed it
because the game that I loved and
remember I still haven't completed in 30
years later but when I was older I
completed an old Zelda from asess that I
haven't completed when I was a kid for
the simple reason of that when I was a
kid my English was not that good I
couldn't understand what to do and then
when I was older I said oh jeez that was
easy it tells you what to do yeah can
you tell me about your first computer
game or the first game you played or the
first game you saw the first game I
remember playing a lot was pilot Wings
on the snz my dad got a snz for
Christmas so Super Nintendo
Entertainment System you got a snz for
Christmas and let us play every Thursday
and then about 3 months later I remember
getting up in the middle of the night
being thirsty going down for a drink and
finding my dad playing pilot wings and
just being so let down that he didn't
invite me to play it with him and he
just said no go to bed go to bed go to
bed and I was like this is this is so
unfair and that that was my first story
and that's that's when I realized that
parents don't do what they say sometimes
oh well the grown-ups get to do what
they want yeah I guess never understood
um but yeah I have I have full memories
of that game what was your first
computer game oh CRS um other early ones
that I remember um Horus
Horus and the spider sticks in the
memory is one of the earliest ones I
remember on the zedex Spectrum horis
goes skiing I remember yeah horis goes
skiing as well sort of Frogger redressed
and then the skiing one tied on the end
that one was but yeah Horus go skiing
Horus and the spiders some of the early
Z Spectrum ones Scrabble was one Dad
loved playing that so that was always
about The Hobbit that was a fascinating
one we should do a computer file on The
Hobbit written by Philip Mitchell and
Veronica megler who's now AWS it was
sort of virtually The Hobbit that he
played as a text based adventure game
with some graphics but Veronica I
believe had written a very impressive
parone physics system for the whole
thing so it sort of as you played it the
characters would carry on doing things
in the background it would understand
English or English as they put it with
an i um far better of the most
text-based adventure games and you used
to get things like Thorin sits down and
sings about gold or Ty passes as you
sort of sat and do it so yeah that
sticks in the mind don't think I ever
completed it but it was definitely uh
fun when you're sort of five or six year
old what was your first ever what was
the first game computer game you played
or that you were aware of okay so one
certainly a very early one that I can
remember is on the the zx81 which is the
machine I I learned on and as a young
kid I it's an amazing game it's it's 3D
but done in incredibly blocky low
resolution and the sell of it is that
you're being chased around a 3D maze by
a
Tyrannosaurus but it is 1981 so the
graphics aren't brilliant and it starts
off with a little blob in the distance
but underneath there's this text saying
Rex can hear you Rex is getting
closer and this little blob jerks
towards you there's only about four or
five frames of Animation but the final
one is teeth closing over you if you've
really messed up and uh yeah
yeah for like 10 year old me it was a
real heart pounding moment um so just
checking the microphones working then
and what was your the first computer
game you played or um Tetris
obviously um it's it was very addictive
I remember people played it so much that
somebody told me that he observed their
all parking cars it was one free spot
and then somebody parked in and they
fully expected them to all
disappear
fantastic and then um in my part-time
job when I was a student my boss played
the blockout it was it now forgotten 3D
version of Tetris oh wow okay which
actually requires
quite you know an impressive um spatial
like uh perception and Imagination
because you can also twist uh turn them
in Space the the pieces so you can
rotate them in different yes the can be
rotated different ctions and they are
properly threedimensional they're not
just you know expanded two dimensional
ones and she was excellent she was like
it was um I couldn't even see the pieces
it was like very early on on comput F we
had one contributor he was world
champion Tetris oh wow okay amazing um
just so I can check the mics working
what was your first computer game or
what was the first game that you played
first computer game obviously the
Pokemon ones are the best um but I I
think I probably played Mario before
that I was very much a Game Boy okay
sounds good sounds good yeah bit of
Super Mario yeah um I'm trying to think
what that my first introdution to Mario
would have been I think I kind of came
in with Super Mario Kart which is quite
quite late on in maros anyway actually
before we start just so I can check that
the levels are okay um what was your
first computer game that you played or a
computer game the first Compu probably
Prince of Persia Prince of Persia okay
what that noise probably I don't recall
and then I probably played loads of
Pokémon Pokémon all right okay makes
sense how do it sound yeah that was
[Music]
good oh that's very difficult I can't
remember it's so long yeah what was the
first one you remember enjoying playing
then should mean okay so first it's bit
difficult because I was still in China
at that time so I only know by the
Chinese name okay was in Chinese
no I don't that so these are the ones
which you have the kind of different
levels to the games you have floors yeah
and you connected by letters you go up
and down being chased by something you
try to avoid those yeah okay yeah I know
the time I know the sort of thing but do
you know the name or yeah so maybe
something like um we used to play one
called mic Miner and one called Chucky
egg okay um but then more advanced ones
yeah all sorts first one I played was
probably Sonic on the Master
System that was good fun probably never
got past level one cuz I can't remember
how old I was but very young um first
one I really remember getting into a bit
older was Age of Empires 2 um which was
absolutely fantastic and I've been an
RTS gamer pretty much ever since my
father used to have a ZX Spectrum so I
played a tick attack and a game called
River raid and mic Miner and stuff like
this but only at the very beginning a
little bit I didn't play on it much plus
you could never get the tape to Lad
could you and then you know into the
'90s we used to play games like doom and
things like that and I still do actually
I think you're the first person who's
mentioned doom and that's a
travesty actually I I yeah I mean I I
actually play Doom and Doom 2 this year
right I still play them because I dis
like them a
lot what was the first computer game you
played or were aware of tell me about
that that's that's our soundcheck
question for the year
wow that's a great question um so age
seven at a friend's house I saw a
spectrum 48k playing the very very
simple Flight Simulator game that came I
don't know if it came with it but it one
like the Horizon thing that came with
though you know which was like bundled
around or was like adjacent to like
Sinclair research and I was I that was
the first game I ever saw I thought wow
and then according to Folklore my
parents they uh my friend then quit the
thing quit the the the the flight
simulator and then he uh typed in a
little program and just all these
numbers were scrolling up the screen you
know the basic that came with it and my
mom said she'd never seen me so
captivated by anything and as a result
of that for my eighth birthday I got a
spectrum so and you know 40 years later
I am I'm still very thankful for seeing
Ian pook's computer or whoever it was I
think that was his name you know from
from like you know
1983 you know then a career in in coding
gaming and stuff absolutely yeah yeah
exactly that is a lot can be traced back
to that one that one moment like so many
of us I'm sure we have yeah first
computer game that I remember playing
was uh Sim City Sim City 1 okay was it
good was you in retrospect
no but at the time it was amazing yeah
yeah yeah yeah did you was that the one
way you could send like a a massive
Alien Invasion and destroy the city was
no that was Sim City 2000 which which is
a much better game
to be fair yeah I do remember doing that
anyway anyway microphone is definitely
working I've done the sound shck
question you haven't I about the uh
computer game yes I think I suggested
that one yeah you might have done I
can't remember in the spiders or The
Hobbit or something something similar y
fantastic yeah I see I keep thinking
about mine and I dily Thompson's
decathlon was a big one I remember
seeing someone playing the text game
that I think was The Hobbit at the time
but I remember what the first one I
played was probably Atari combat if I'm
honest that's probably it uh right we
are recording um recing what are we
going to be looking at today
then